bonjour merci d'avoir accepté notre
invitation leur première question qui
préoccupe les responsables des
politiques et même les français en
général y aura-t-il oui ou non une
seconde vague en france oh moi
personnellement je n'y crois pas malgré
le nombre de clusters de foyers
infectieux je n'y crois pas parce que il
faut savoir que bon il ya une hypothèse
celle d'entre eux possèdent anthropocène
c'est à dire que la dernière ère
géologique au cours de l'ère humaine y
est toutes les empreintes l'emprunt des
activités humaines est telle qu'elle
modifie t va la biodiversité les
ressources naturelles ce qui est fait
que la terre l'organisme suprême elle
opère elle opère parfois dont des
régulations c'est à dire qu'une sorte de
catharsis purifie un petit peu
l'ambiance est une
il faut savoir que quand on est dans un
grand trouble comme l'apparition de la
couronne a rappelé russe eh bien il ya
beaucoup de techno et cetera on est dans
une ambiance très spéciale comme
souvient pendant la guerre 39 40 que
j'ai vécu il y avait une sorte de
mysticisme qui s'empare des gens avec un
nombre de facs news alors je pense que
elle n'arrivera pas parce que justement
est d'abord elle peut muter c'est
coronavirus et mutent fréquemment et
c'est pourquoi on attend beaucoup eu des
vaccins celle dernier répit puisque voir
au niveau des médicaments on a vu qui a
rien n'est rien appareils avec le
phénomène raul qu'il dont le produit
dans son remède ne jouer que sur des
formes légères mais quand le cornard
virus devient un petit peu plus agressif
on n'a rien eux disposent rien donc il
reste vaccin alors le vaccin il y en a
trois qui sont en piste sur les trois
grands continents alors on attend le
premier qui va sortir mais je ne pense
pas qui sera fin prêt parce que on
compte arrive habituellement 18 mois
pour sortir un vaccin
or 18 mois vous pensiez que le preneur
au virus à l'otan de muter ensuite ceux
qui ceux qui vont apparaître que je
pense que c'est des petits bouts de
ficelle
les raccords déterra mais l'essentiel
l'efficacité donc d'une ce vaccin il
faut qu'ils atteignent au moins 65 à 70%
d'immunité qui n'est alors jean-pierre
wilhem la direction générale de la santé
a alerté sur une hausse des tests
positifs notamment chez les jeunes
adultes est ce que c'est quelque chose
que vous trouvez inquiétant c'est
inquiétant parce que je ne faisais pas
beaucoup testament maintenant dès lors
qu'on qui détestent et automatiquement
vous verrez des gens qui sont positifs
il faut savoir que maintenant ils vont
le faut savoir que les jeunes ont eu des
comportements très laxiste il ya vu un
certain relâchement et la clé réside
donc dans nos comportements
alors ce qui fait que le fait d'attendre
un petit peu le vaccin qui va être notre
sauveur
je les crois pas beaucoup parce que s'il
atteint 30%
ça suffit pas il faut donc une immunité
qui soit valable
et le fait aussi que les jeunes gens
font la fête
il va y avoir plein de l'infection dans
des clusters qui grimpe ou bien qu'on
sache exactement le fait de porter les
masques et les effets variés intérêts
ils n'en tiennent pas compte et le fait
qu'ils attrapent la cette maladie ça va
faire en sorte que l'immunité va grimper
mais justement vous vous ne croyez pas à
une deuxième vague de colis de 19 en
france mais est ce que vous pensez que
l'état serait pression d'une deuxième
vague plus à même de gérer la situation
qu'au cours de la première dans toute
façon on ne pourra pas refaire 1re
confinement total comme on l'a vécu on
va le cible et on va le cibler c'est à
dire que ça va être régionales c'est
suivant comme chez nous dans la mayenne
ou lauaki bron et c'est donc on va le
ciblé parce que psychologiquement les
gens ne sont plus prêts dès lors que
déjà ils ont un comportement laxiste si
on leur demande je pense que tout va
s'écrouler et que personne
va ne va s'y soumettre alors que tout
simplement le fait de porter un masque
et tout le problème est là tout le monde
devrait le savoir mais il y en a qui
l'ignorent
et il ya aussi le fait d'aller dans les
restaurants d'aller faire le il ya des
mariages il ya des cérémonies etc
les gens ne sont pas disciplinés le jour
où ils sont disciplinés et bien les tout
va rentrer dans l'ordre vous que la
meilleure arme contre le coronavirus en
france ça reste ce masque qu'on a
longtemps décrié mais oui y'a que ça
plus évidemment la distanciation un mec
pour moi ne suffit pas parce que dès
lors que vous parler fort revu il ya des
postillons qui vont à plus d'un mètre et
demi de 2 mettez c'est simple à
comprendre cela alors le masque bailly
vous protège tout simplement pour tout
le monde et son masque et puis
parallèlement pour qu'on passe la
sérologie qu'on continue qu'on
l'amplifient pour savoir qui est atteint
et et on voit partir de là qu'il ya une
évolution positive
alors justement vous parliez des tests
de dépistage olivier verrons a dit et
qu'ils avaient augmenté ils sont passés
à 500000 par semaine à présent c'est
suffisant non c'est pas on avait au
départ c'était sept cent mille ans mais
déjà 500 milles ça commence à venir
mais plus on en fait plus on sent une
investigation total de la population
très bien bien ça sera un mot de la fin
jean pierre viel et merci d'avoir
répondu à nos questions je rappelle que
vous êtes ancien membre de médecins sans
frontières médecins chirurgiens et
auteur également du livre tout savoir
sur les virus et y faire face donc
publié aux éditions de fin merci
beaucoup merci